[Musik]
herzlich willkommen wie heute zu einem
neuen video auf einem kanal meine lieben
freunde ich sie mal wieder mit
deutschland schreibst du so dieter
kupfernagel sprachen lernen sondern ich
haben vor einigen monaten schon mal ein
video gemacht mit dem titel witzigste zu
video er war alle fische können
schwimmen alle fische für den spirit
alle fische wir gerade unschwer erkennen
konnte hat er eine person dabei
kopfhörer auf und in den kopfhörern lief
extrem laute rockmusik so dass man die
anderen umweltgeräusche gar nicht
richtig wahrnimmt und dann hat die
andere person die keine kopfhörer auf
hat einen satz ab das kennt spielt jeder
junge netz zwischen freunden
sie selbst sind ja dass freunde vor
fische sind freunde keine freiheit
[Musik]
freiheit keine fische sind freunde und
freundlichkeit
aber da ist immer dazwischen
fische sind freunde bekommen neues wort
das gehört nicht zu freuen und fischer
sind freunde kein futter
fotos die das letzte ist richtig aber
das da vor uns nicht richtig keine
kamera beim geld ist da sind alle
freunde bei fischen slim freunde freunde
ja
[Musik]
während sind penelope während sind mein
glaube blaubeeren jahr sind mein
lieblingsessen weil sie sind blau
blaubeeren flinken blaubeeren sind meist
blaubeeren sind man ist glauben sind
richtig ok blaubeeren sind geil blau im
blau bei meinem glauben ihren vereinen
die begriffe glauben wir dass mein
lieblingsessen weil sie sie weil
glaubwürdig erste wahl
sie lautet weiter sagt heute ganz normal
blaubeere findlings häfen lagen sind
mein lieblingsessen bei 7 lausitz weil
sie ist dass solche glaube ja dass in
meinem sessel weil sie lecker sind sehr
gut sind eingeplant
[Musik]
17.32 kraftwerke deutsche letzten
kollegah lohne
denk mal los
[Musik]
17 33
[Applaus]
[Musik]
diese musik alter dieses aktuelle bambus
hausen am bussen campus hat muss man
muss kämpfen momentanen bambus kaufen
meine bank hamburg
maulwürfe auslaufen
[Musik]
hamburg
[Applaus]
[Musik]
x men sind sofort für rock
ich verstehe nicht wenn die kamera
schmelzen des grases becken
ich habe mich als alten cbs ungerührt
und bauhaus am busfahrer
[Applaus]
das heißt erst wasser bambus haus bambus
haufen das ist ein bambus kauft die
comfort japan müsse aber der sachse ist
noch nicht fertig sind cool sind cool
[Musik]
sein cool voller ganz kurze zwischen
info eben hier am rande und zwar sander
leider ein bisschen plemplem in ihrer
birne sie hat bereits bei ihrem ersten
satz vorhin fehler bei der wiederholung
gemacht und auch jetzt gerade hat sie
ein zu beginn gesagt man muss hoffen
sind schön dann bambus haufen sind cool
und jetzt bei muss haufen ist cool
also fragt euch da einfach nicht
bevor jetzt wird wieder alles neu und
ich wollte mal ist freute sich heute vor
sich drei wochen später 11
[Musik]
denn japan ist klar wer das wollte ich
wieder gefallen hat das gerne einen
daumen hoch unter dem video hier das
video einfach witzig das video aber 2.0
genannt war das erste video das seit er
wieder dabei ist nicht sehr sexy aus
[Musik]